i'm off to burning man for the 10th year
in a row
i'm [ __ ] super excited man a lot of
people say it's
is it weird going to burning man with
your day job because i work for ice
and i say no actually going to burning
man is what inspired
me to work for ice i don't think there's
anything strange
about supporting the president of the
united states and his war on whoever it
happens to be against i actually got
this whip from work
we don't hurt him we just we wake him up
like this because many of them are
sleeping
they're lazy we are one consciousness
you know we are all part of the human
family
but i do believe that if you come to the
country and you are with your family
that we do need to probably put you in
two different jails i spoke to the
entities
and they told me jail is good
okay the aliens are very very impressed
with our jails
they love our jails when we're all in
the playa
we're the same and when we leave the
playa i'm gonna [ __ ] get you